Hey, Jewish apologetics, unmute
yourself. What's up? Yeah, hi. How are
you, Sam?
We had a couple of people claiming to be
Jews and attacking. So, you're not one
of them You were not that guy?
>> No, no, no. I always good faith. I
always try to be nice. So, yeah,
hopefully we can have a discussion.
Now, the the apologetics, what do you
do apologetics in regards to what faith?
Uh so, I defend Judaism and I
[clears throat] try to disprove
Christianity and Islam. So, Yeah, well,
that means you're lost because without
Jesus, your religion is a joke. So, So,
we're talking about the Trinity. No,
it's true. I mean, you can laugh, man. I
don't want you to be upset. So, we're
talking about the Trinity. So, what's
>> from the scriptures? Right. So, I I
heard a lot of your videos. I watched
them and I heard you say that
Yeah. Yeah, so I heard that you said
that in scripture in the Old Testament,
you would never find
plural verbs that refer to one person.
Right?
>> 1 Samuel 28:13?
No. So, I did find some. So, I would
like to bring it up and see if you have
any objection to them. Sure. All right,
go ahead. Okay, so the first one would
be Job chapter 18,
the beginning of the chapter.
So, basically we see
uh you say Bildad. I don't know how to
say it in English. Probably it's the
same name. Okay, good. So, he replies to
Job and he refers to him in plural
nouns.
Job 18 what?
Uh the beginning of the yeah, sure.
Eight Job Job 18 verse 1 and 2, I
believe.
How long must That your words. Show
understanding then we can talk.
Okay?
What?
You said Job 18, right? I'm in Job 18.
Where?
>> Yeah, correct. So, over here we can see
that Bildad answers Job and he if you
can go on, you can open it in
Bible Hub see the plurality. verse Okay,
verse two.
Okay. Why are we regarded as beasts and
dense in your eyes? Okay, let's go
there.
And so, that's going to refute the
entire case for the Trinity. All right,
let's see.
from your Hebrew scriptures. Yeah.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay, then all right.
Job 18:3, right?
Mhm. Well, yeah, the beginning. Okay,
let's see cuz you said
verse three cuz it's not No, I think
verse two. Let me open up and make sure.
I think it's verse two.
Yeah, Job Job here. Job 18
Okay. Okay, verse two.
All right, let's go to verse two. All
right, maybe it's verse 10 in your
Bible.
Okay.
>> No, that's three. Go to two.
All right, I know. I know. I know.
Okay, so
How long
All right.
Where? You put is You put is plural.
Where? Where? Where? Hold on. Take it
easy.
>> The third You put
Yeah, that's plural.
And it's referring to to Job. Plus the
the sixth one that says gain
understanding, it's also
plural verb and it's referring to Job.
Okay, so now
this is now supposed to prove what
again?
Okay, so that shows that they are like
Job is one person, is still being
referred in plurality. So, means in the
Bible if God is being referred to in
plurality, does not mean that he's
plural person. It just uh using uh how
do you call it? It's called like
respect. follow. Nope. Because in Job
33:4, so now I'm going to meet you at
your where you're at. Job 33:4, who made
man?
Let me go Let me open it up. 33:4.
doesn't follow. So, you're wrong there.
But why doesn't follow exactly? Because
the same Job tells you that the God who
created is not just one person, it's God
in the spirit. Open up Job 33:4. Read it
for me.
>> Okay, yeah, yeah. Okay, but just do you
agree first of all the first verse I
gave you? You agree that's plurality?
No, I know it's plurality, but it
doesn't mean it's because Job is one
person. There's going to be other
reasons that's related
>> Job is one person. What do you mean?
Buddy, if you're not going to listen,
I'm going to cuss you out. Listen to
what I said. Okay, let me see. Job is
not one person. I know you're excited to
prove your demonic doctrines. Take it
easy.
I said no, it doesn't follow that if the
plurals are used for Job, it's because
that it only has Job in mind. And I will
go back and research it and I'm going to
show you that there's a reason for the
plural. Just like in 1 Samuel 28:13, the
spirit of Samuel comes up, but he goes,
"I see Elohim rising." And it's plural.
Take it easy, buddy.
But nonetheless, deal with Job 33:4, the
spirit of God made me.
Okay.
Yeah, so I don't see the distinction. I
have a spirit, God has a spirit. It's
part of me.
>> I'm asking you Did God
create man with a spirit?
Exactly.
So, is the spirit
>> word, with his spirit. You're going to
keep talking over me? Then I'm going to
cuss you out. Okay, I'm sorry.
Take it easy. I'm going to shish kebab
you. Just be patient. Is the spirit
identical to God?
It's part of him.
I didn't ask you that. Is it identical
to God?
Yes.
So, God and the spirit are one in the
same?
Exactly. Then you're lying. Why? Cuz God
will pour out his spirit. What is he
pouring out?
What Again, what is he what? I didn't
hear. When God says, "I'll put my spirit
or pour out my spirit,"
what is he pouring out?
His spirit.
But you just said the spirit is God. So,
God is saying, "I will pour out myself?"
It's part of himself, yeah.
No, let's go again. See, you're playing
games with me. What do you mean? part of
God, is it identical to God or there's a
distinction?
So, okay, so it's exactly like my spirit
is identical to me or has distinction?
It's the same thing. You're not
>> I'm not. So, then don't use a false
analogy cuz unless you think your God
Hashem is a man like you and has
testicles,
you're a creature
and even then your spirit is not
identical to your flesh. So, is your
spirit your flesh?
I'm not my flesh. My flesh is just a
cover. Is your spirit your flesh? Answer
the questions before I cuss you out,
man.
>> No, it's not my flesh because the flesh
is not me. So, then there's a
distinction.
>> Okay, so there's a distinction. So, is
the spirit distinct from God or
identical to God?
I identical.
Is the spirit God or is the spirit
distinct from God because he belongs to
God?
Okay, it's kind of confusing to me
because I'm not like a philosophical
person. I want to see in the scripture
you can show me.
What? I just showed you.
Joel 2:28-29, God I will pour out my
spirit.
Mhm.
Okay. So, let's go with you. God is
saying, "I will pour out me, myself upon
you." Is that how you want to interpret
this?
Yeah.
So, God is saying, "I'm going to pour
out me, my
self on you?"
Yeah, you can see all over the Yeah, you
can see all over the place in the
scriptures. God says, "I'll put myself
in you. I'll cover myself within you."
Like you can see all You can see all
over the places.
>> but he says to Moses, "I'm going to take
the spirit that's on you and put it on
the 70 elders." He's saying, "I'm going
to take myself that's on you and put it
on the 70 elders?" Part, yeah, part of
myself. See, there we go again.
What does it mean part? Does it mean
they're the same or there's a
distinction?
They are the same, but you can split You
can part You can how do you say?
Split again?
>> Split Not split, but whatever. They are
the same, but you can take part of
So, it's distinct.
You can call this
distinction, yeah. Okay, so now you just
refuted yourself. You proved there's a
distinction in God.
Okay, no problem. Now, okay.
>> go Wait, be patient. So, now you just
justified that the plurals for God is
not akin to Job because you just
acknowledged there's a distinction
within God, God and the spirit working
together.
So, how did you refute me?
Okay, I didn't I didn't try to refute. I
just wanted to say cuz I remember that
you said that it's non-existing. So, I I
did find a place. I want to show you.
I'm going to go back and see. I don't
trust you representing my words, but
nonetheless,
uh there's always a reason why plurals
are using used even for singular
subjects because even in the scriptures,
you have, for example, Jacob in Genesis
28 and it says, "He will spread to the
west and east." But he didn't spread to
the west and east. His descendants did,
right?
Right. So, the plurality would refer to
who?
His descendants. You got it. So, I see
you just buried yourself. So, secondly,
Right. But what does that have to do
with Job? Oh, well, it's because Job
also doesn't just stand for himself. I'm
going to get there if you're patient.
Take it easy. I'm going to shish kebab
you. Be patient.
I know you're laughing.
No, no, I'm just blowing my nose. It's
not laughing. Okay. Now, when we go back
to Genesis 4:10, when it says, "The
blood of your brother cries out to me."
Is the word blood plural?
I need to open it up. Where again?
In Genesis 4:10 cuz I'm going to show
you what the rabbi said. Let me check.
4:10, one second.
You think you have me. You don't because
that Job example doesn't prove your
case. It's going to prove mine.
In Genesis 4:10 and I'm going to show
you how the rabbis interpret in your
Talmud.
>> Yeah, yeah, the the blood is plural,
yeah. Plural. Okay, so now what did the
rabbi say? Why did God say to Cain, "The
bloods of your brother cry out to me."
Do you know what the Talmud says?
What?
It says because when you kill one
person, you kill a whole nation.
As if, yeah.
No, it says when you kill one person,
you kill a whole nation because of the
descendants. So, now since your rabbi
said the reason why it's bloods plural
because in
Abel, the whole nation that would have
arose from him were killed.
Now, you understand why even if I take
what you said, plurals with Job, that
doesn't help your case. It represents
Job and those that would spring from his
loins. So, it didn't help your case.
Yeah, but that's his speech. It's not
confirmed by his blood. If I talk to
you, for example, and I refer to
plurality, doesn't talk to you.
>> 28?
Did you want me to write in Genesis 28
when he says to Jacob
>> I agree with you Genesis 28, but Okay,
so I can give you more examples. So,
let's not change the game.
No, I'm asking you.
>> the plural if the plural
is used to indicate that a person
doesn't stand alone, but he represents
even those that will descend from him
and the singular can function in the
same way,
you have no case.
No, I would agree with you. It depends
on the context. The context in Job does
not refer to his descendants. No, that's
your assumption because you're not
listening to what I said. When you talk
to a person,
even though he's one, the plural can
account for that that one will stand for
those who descend from him, whether you
like it or not. And you agreed to that.
That's why in Genesis 4:10, the plural
is used for the bloods of
Abel.
So, you didn't make your case. So, let's
come back to plurality of God. Okay, now
listen, I concede I'll concede it
because I have another point I want to
point out. Okay, wait, wait. Say it
again. You did what? I'll concede it.
Good. So, so much for that. But now deal
with the fact that in Genesis 1 cuz
that's why I went to Job 33:4.
Okay. Job 33:4 to show you you
acknowledge the spirit is a part of God.
So, if he's a part of God, he's not the
whole of God. So, there's that
distinction.
So, in Genesis 1:2, who is present at
creation?
Genesis 1:2
God's spirit.
The spirit of God, right?
Correct. And the verb hovering.
You know where else it's used?
Where?
Deuteronomy 32:10-11. Open up read it
for me.
Deuteronomy 32, 1 second.
But what verse?
Deuteronomy 32:10-11, yes.
10 to 11.
Okay.
Okay. What does it say that Hashem I
don't know because I don't think you
like to pronounce the divine name,
right?
Right. Okay, Hashem out of respect for
you. Thank you.
>> What does it say? Like an eagle
hovering.
That's the same [clears throat]
Yes.
Deuteronomy 32:10-11
it likens Hashem to an eagle hovering
over her nest.
You see it?
Yeah. Hovering shows awareness. An eagle
must be aware
this nest is hers and these are her
offspring and it hovers over the nest
for the specific purpose of providing,
caring, protecting. And that's why
Hashem is likened to an eagle hovering
over you cuz you are her nest, right?
Yeah.
So, the verb shows consciousness,
correct?
Yeah, I'm speaking about God. God is
conscious, so yes. Yes, but in Genesis
1:2, the same verb is used of the
spirit. So, what does that tell us about
the spirit hovering over the watery
surface of the earth?
Yeah, I see what you're saying.
So, what does that imply?
Okay, according to what you're trying to
say, there's a there's a distinction, so
it's a different person. No, no, it's a
different person. What does it What does
it imply that the spirit hovers when
that shows conscious
activity?
That the entity who's hovering must have
awareness.
Yeah.
So, what does that imply about the
spirit?
The spirit is aware.
Oh, okay. Now you just ended up helping
me make the case for Trinity stronger
cuz now I'm going to ask you in Genesis
1:26. And don't bring up the angel
interpretation, that will get boring.
When God said
in our image,
right? Mhm.
>> When God said let us make man in our
image,
and in verse 2, we see the spirit is
there. You just admit that the verb
hovering shows the spirit has awareness.
In light of Job 33:4 where it says the
spirit of God has made me,
you're now going to help me prove that
God is speaking to the spirit. So, why
is he speaking to the spirit?
Okay, um
Let me see, 1 second. Wait, why is he
speaking to the spirit again? You you're
talking about 20 26? Yeah, let me read
it again Let me repeat it again so you
don't attack straw men and then run from
it.
In Job 33:4, it says the spirit of God
has made me and it uses the same verb.
The spirit of God has made me.
Job 33:4, you read it. Same verb.
Genesis 1:26, there's the verb again.
Let us make man in our image after our
likeness.
And in verse 2, the spirit is there. So,
when I combine Genesis 1:2, hear me out,
then you try to refute me,
and I combine Genesis 1:26 and Job 33:4,
now I have from your Tanakh the proof
God is speaking to the spirit because
it's the spirit that made man with God.
Same verb.
Genesis 1:26, let us make
same verb as Job 33:4, the spirit of God
has made me.
And in verse 2, we see the spirit is
there hovering, meaning the spirit is
conscious and aware. So, God is speaking
to the spirit. So, why is God speaking
to the spirit if the spirit is not a
distinct person?
Okay, so I would say that over here the
case you're trying to make is the exact
case I can make and
in Proverbs chapter 8 when it speaks
about the
Hokhmah, which is the wisdom.
>> case? You don't you know that
say that's Jesus? So, don't go there.
It's not going to help your case.
>> Why? Wisdom is aware and the wisdom says
he was there at the beginning.
>> And who told you that we don't use
wisdom of Proverbs 8 to show that's an
actual conscious divine person who
becomes the Messiah?
You don't know what you're talking
about.
>> No, so so I'm just I'm curious. So,
you're saying that wisdom is the
Messiah? Yes. According
>> Take Take part in it.
Yes, that was the view of Christians.
But before you jump there, even if you
add wisdom there, good. That's three.
You just argued for the Trinity. Right,
so then where's the angel of the of the
Lord? That's four. Because the angel of
the Lord is wisdom and word because if I
show you in Jewish sources
that the wisdom is said to be in the
pillar of cloud, Sirach 24:1-4, which
your rabbis quoted, and it's the angels
in the pillar of cloud. And then in
Wisdom of Solomon chapter 18, we're told
it's the word of God that came down and
destroyed Israelites. I just made the
case that the angel is the wisdom and
the word using Jewish sources. See?
Again, so so Hold on, wait, wait, wait.
You ran from my argument. I'll get to
your wisdom. I'm not like you.
No, I didn't I didn't understand your
argument. Come back to Genesis 1. Do you
now admit that God is speaking to the
spirit?
You ran.
You didn't answer. You ran.
>> Okay, so so so
speaking to the spirit is an option,
yes. I can't say not, but there could be
other options. For example, he could be
speaking
Okay, for example, he could be he could
be speaking to the
in where is it? In Psalms, I think 80
something. I'm sure you know of it.
Speaking to his counsel to brother
because Isaiah 44:24
says that God made everything by
himself. There are no angels involved.
That's not going to work if unless
>> No, that's consulting.
So, what?
Consulting. You can see here in Genesis
1, you can see that God himself made it.
It's not consulting. It's let us do this
together. There is no consultation. He's
telling them, let us create. That's an
action that he's involving others in.
And Isaiah 44:24 says no one other than
God performed that act. Your arguments
are not going to work. You're reading
into your text and I'm not. I'm going
with what the text says. It's not
consultation. It's let us make man.
That's not consultation. That's saying,
"Hey, join me. Let's make man."
And then I gave you proof. Job 33:4, the
spirit did make man. So, at least God
was talking to the spirit.
Yeah, so okay.
Um
can we speak about the Before we go
there, we I'll go with you. Before
[clears throat] we go there,
do you now admit that in light of your
Tanakh, which I didn't use the New
Testament, Genesis 1:2, Genesis 1:26,
Job 33:4, we now have a clear-cut case
from your Tanakh, God is speaking to the
spirit cuz the spirit did create. But
since God created alone, that means the
spirit, though distinct from God and God
can talk to the spirit, he's still one
God.
Yeah, I hear I see what you're saying.
Good. Now we're closer to the Trinity
from the Tanakh.